Kamilah
from nigeria spent years as a forced
prostitute in Italy a year ago she was
discovered by the police and deported
she prefers to remain anonymous during
filming binning City is a hub of
prostitution and human trafficking local
women are drawn into the traffickers web
with promises of a better life in Europe
only to find themselves forced into
prostitution back in Nigeria Camila
wants to start a new life but her
feelings of shame or such that she has
yet to visit her family will she find
the strength to meet them
kamilla still has a list documenting her
harrowing experience it's a record of
her earnings from working the streets in
Florence Italy she had to record every
single euro which she then had to
surrender to her pimp or Madame who was
also from Nigeria back home she's found
support and refuge at a women's shelter
run by Catholic nuns she spent most of
her time in Italy imprisoned in a tiny
room with no chance of escape she
collected my phone she was known I was
without phone I could not call my
parents
she might trick me and beat me up call
me Oh sort of named I thought that happy
mean I don't want to pay her back her
money eventually Camilla was picked up
by the Italian police and repatriated to
Benin City she says she still feels too
weak to cope on her own and she's afraid
of being seen as a failure since she
returned from Europe penniless she's not
sure how she'll manage
three months later a few days ago Camila
rented a small apartment in Bonita City
the nuns from the women's shelter helped
her furnish it I never think that we'll
have this kind of place why is that
because of the way I came I came and
empty-handed Lea I didn't come with
anything so I I was frustrated I never
believed that I'm going to have some
with a place like this to stay so I'm
very aware and very very happy that
would be at least I can't
it's what I want I sleep our word pop
I'm okay I don't have anybody disturbing
me I'm just okay I'm just so fine I'm
okay meanwhile Camila has established
contact with some old friends via social
media
loneliness has been one of the most
distressing challenges to deal with but
she still dreads the prospect of
reuniting with her family since setting
off for Italy more than eight years ago
contact with her family has been limited
to just a few phone calls she told no
one in her family of the terrible things
that happened to her in Europe and her
home village is just a half an hour
drive away no phone I would because I
don't want to I don't just want to
bedtime I start picking all talking
about it so I'm going to remember some
sanctity that I don't even want to
remember so I don't just want to talk
about the past we temple mom the lack of
jobs and bleak prospects for the future
affect many young people in Nigeria
Camila to dreamt of a better life abroad
that is exactly what the sex traffickers
promise a well paid job in well-off
Europe
they then smuggled the young women
across borders with fake papers often
disguising them as refugees experts say
there are several thousand such cases
every year in Benin City alone
the next day camilla is making a rare
venture out in public that means putting
on a wig she feels more comfortable when
she doesn't think she'll be recognized
she's off to a school to tell her story
and she hopes to prevent more young
girls falling prey to sex trafficking
gangs many of them that country was that
what my mother took me to Danielle's
Camila knows that very few human
traffickers are ever prosecuted not in
Europe and not in Nigeria
that's why educational efforts are so
important
Camila was invited by the nuns from the
women's refuge to give talks to
schoolgirls today they're in a suburb of
pfennig city more than half the girls in
this region know of incidents involving
human trafficking from their own
families I feel like if I'm in the shoes
of those people have loved you that they
are trapped there and they can't even
come to their country to see that
experience or or teach teach difficult
stay away from others kind of stuff some
of them it's not awkward but the
appearance does send them there you know
the stress of making money
I'm really happy for to stand out and
come to this school today to tell us
more about Nicole and so that Camilla
and the nuns are a well practice team
first a nun tells them about human
traffickers and their tricks and false
promises and she tells them that much of
what they've been told about life in
Europe is misleading I promise you I'm
going to check you over cause there you
have never have you doped before many of
you many are brothers and sisters either
the assembled girls then get a
first-hand example of the dangers that
potentially await them courtesy of
Camilla the story she tells is not
sanitized
it's one of beatings and brutal
exploitation
every night so please stop be the same
and don't allow anybody to deceive your
ticket oh it's Ali yeah it was she tells
us how hard it was to begin talking to
school girls about her experiences
the first times were especially
difficult things like that all like
shaking things like that box I tried to
goes on when I continue on talking to
their mouths like funny tourists to
speak on on all that sister Bibiana has
more than 10 years experience working
with victims of forced prostitution
she's grateful for women like Camila who
has overcome her own fears to help other
young women avoid a similar fate
I really admire how College how goodness
um try reaching how call it Chinese but
she doesn't want anybody didn't meet you
what I have to do not my aha
a juju temple in Benin City many sex
traffickers send their victims to such
temples before their departure to see
priests supposedly endowed with magical
powers
insiders report that some juju priests
make the young women swear an oath of
unconditional obedience
this priest refuses to confirm the
allegations while on camera although he
does issue a warning about taking vows
seriously the gods he says seek revenge
on those who break their ODEs once they
deny it the person will die they die
within seven days by Thunder Oh
kamila refuses to be intimidated anymore
right now she's preoccupied with a
different matter she came across her own
sister in a women's shelter she too was
exploited by human traffickers recently
she was held captive for several months
in neighboring Ghana before managing to
escape Camilla now blames herself for
not having warned her sister earlier she
also knows that she can no longer put
off meeting with her family a few days
later Camilla goes back to her home
village it's a nerve-racking Drive what
will their mothers say after such a long
absence will their family be
disappointed to see her returning
without any money saved up from Europe
but her worries proved unfounded I'm
happy to see my doctor with you and she
looks very nice
I'm ready happy but I'll never know what
is going on rice with egg and chilli
sauce the meal that kamila enjoyed as a
child she decides not to tell her family
for now about her experiences in Europe
for now she's just happy that her mother
isn't asking questions
her mother had warned her about leaving
it will be quite troubled she'd want me
not to do such thing and I went they are
they talking to my thoughts I found
myself inside this situation so if I
should tell her I don't think she would
really would you like that kids likely
and she will not be happy about so I
don't take her hotel I don't just want
to tell her I just want to keep this
secret the family prays to give thanks
for her return kamila believes her
mother may suspect what really happened
80% of forced prostitutes in Nigeria
come from the Benin City area even
people in remote regions have heard the
rumors perhaps one day Camilla will
manage to talk to her mother about what
really happened during her stay in
Europe